lifting the mandate is a big step  forward according to businesses on the  strip now the strats vp telling us today  they will this will help las vegas get  to that full recovery stage they believe  it will help with convention attendance  and international travel ahead of the  spring and summer season now the head of  dre's at the cromwell says this is a  breath of fresh air  for our employees i think it's  definitely nice for them they don't have  to you know constantly having to put  their mask over their nose and so forth  but we are any employee that doesn't  feel comfortable taking their mask off  and wants to continue to wear a mask we  support them 100 percent  dustin dre also adding that even though  their venue is half indoors and half  outdoors healthy and safety is priority  for both guests and employees